- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
I wanted to talk today
about a different kind
of irregular plural.
So we've been talking
about regular plurals
where you take a word and you add an S.
So for example, the word dog becomes dogs.
You add an S.
And this is the regular plural here.
But I've been talking
about the irregular plural,
the plural, the multiple form of a verb
that is not regular, irregular.
But today I figured we'd
talk about something called
the base plural.
Which I will illustrate for
you using our friend the sheep.
Now, sheep is a very strange word in that
it doesn't matter whether not
there's more than one of them.
The form of the word always looks the same
whether it's one sheep or two sheep.
It's an irregular plural
you don't add an S to.
This is called a base plural
'cause the base sheep,
the thing that you would
normally add this particle S to
doesn't change whether it's
singular sheep or plural sheep.
So that's you know.
There was one sheep...
on the hill.
There's a sentence.
What if we put another little
baby sheep on that hill?
A little lamb.
Well now the sentence looks like this.
Two sheep...
on the hill.
Now the only difference
between these two sentences
is that there's one sheep and two sheep
and therefore that means that the verb
changes to a plural conjugation.
So there was one sheep.
There were two sheep on the hill.
But everything else
stays exactly the same.
One sheep, two sheep.
This is very strange, it's a base plural.
So in standard English,
the form is two sheep...
and not two sheeps.
You see.
Now, there are more words
that do behave this way.
So let's go investigate.
So there are a small number of words
that also behave this
way, the way sheep does,
these weird sheep plurals,
these base plurals.
One of them is fish.
So you could say the fish
are plentiful this season,
but you could also say,
you know, the fish...
is delicious.
You could say the bison migrate west
or you could also say
the bison migrates west
indicating a single bison, you see.
Bison can be singular or plural.
Fish can be singular or plural.
As is so frequently the case,
there is a special exception
regarding the word fishes,
which you may have heard before,
and fishes is a word that we would use
when we're talking
about individual species
of fish.
And fish is the word that we would use
to refer to individual fish.
So let's say your uncle Marty
is a prodigious fisherman
and he catches,
he goes fly fishing one weekend,
he comes back, he has 30 fish.
Marty caught...
30 fish.
But let's say on the other hand
your aunt Marta is a
prodigious marine biologist
and she studies 30
different types of fish.
You would say Marta studies...
30 fishes.
And that doesn't mean that she
studies 30 individual fish.
That means she studies 30 types of fish.
That's the difference.
Fishes is referring to species.
Fish refers to individuals.
That's how you'd use them in the plural.
So to review,
there's this entire class
of words called base plurals
where the word itself, the
base, doesn't take an S
for the plural, it's just the same.
The singular is the same as the plural.
So that gives us words like sheep,
fish,
and bison.
There aren't a ton of English
words that behave this way
where the plural is the
same as the singular.
I just wanted to make you aware
of some of the most common ones.
There are also more
examples in the exercises.
So I just wanted you to be aware of them.
You can learn anything.
David out.